Formula One is basically my life my
world I like to battle against the
world's fastest 19 other drivers no
other thing makes me happier than
driving
when formula one held its first Chinese
Grand Prix in Shanghai five-year-old
joking was in the stands cheering on his
Idol Fernando Alonso now Joe is
competing against Alonso after he became
China's first full-time F1 racer last
year
I really started fell in love with
racing my first ever attempt or try when
I was a kid around seven years old we
went to a indoor go-kart track and I was
actually very scared I was sitting in
the two-seated go-kart my dad was
driving but then the first time I tried
the absolutely falling in love with the
sports and I really want to do every
weekend after schools as a kid I grew up
having that dream
the most challenged part for me in
Formula One is probably before the first
race a lot of people will stop about me
saying I won't be fast I'll be last but
for me I would just really focus I knew
I deserved to be there and to get my
first points in my first season is
amazing Joe is a very very talented
driver we have been following him from
the junior category we were fully
convinced that he can be a very strong
addition to our team and he confirmed
our expectation last year imagine a
route coming to Formula One and being
able to score a point at a very close
trades to have a Chinese driver of such
a level is beneficial not only for our
team but for the entire former one
China is f1's biggest Market globally in
terms of unique TV viewers which reached
over 70 million as of 2021 but that
hasn't translated into comparable
dollars for the franchise the
cancellation of the Chinese Grand Prix
for four straight year in 2023 has been
another setback but Joe's emergence
might be the key to turning things
around now in his second season Joe has
already attracted sponsorship deals from
Global brands any International Sports
coming to China for it to truly become
popular it needs to have relevance and
nothing builds relevance like having
your own Superstar and Champion to
support and we've seen that in other
sports basketball with the emergence of
Yao Ming tennis and Lena how those
superstars on the global stage have
really boosted the sport and now we have
zoguan yew on the grid of formula one
that will also stimulate commercial
interest hopefully when formula one
comes back to China next year it will
start to really reap the rewards and
grow the popularity for me to be the
first Chinese or the only Chinese in F1
I definitely see what's happened back
home as being quite incredible seeing
how many people that's staying up late
to watch the Grand Prix and now all we
need is a Grand Prix in front of the
home crowd because there's so many like
new fans who doesn't know anything about
Motorsports is now actually getting into
that watching all try to understand F1
tradition it costs quite a lot of money
to develop a driver from a young age an
increasingly wealthy middle class will
mean you're having a growing community
that will be interested in their
children perhaps becoming Formula One
drivers there will be many many Chinese
people competing in Motorsports and
formula one in the future I'm only
optimistic that things can get better
from here
foreign